my country there are three million  regards I'd be happy to slaughter Philip  to finish the problem officers have  repeatedly been accused of hunting down  and executing people but they insist all  the killings are the results of  shootouts reporting andrew.galea can be  a lot of things you think about more  about a man I would I'm enough  the night crawlers just a  photojournalist trying to tell this  story it's a collective effort they  hurry to the scene to get a shot of the  body for the authorities can clean up  the site  [Music]  my papa was a surreal Ecola fifty-plus  she just found out her father's death  it's so heartbreaking man jump in psycho  peanut then a bleep I don't give a bleep  are you gonna vomit on me they cover the  scenes you began to fear for your life  we will be vigilant we will be watching  them  they have to actively challenge what's  happening because we know it's wrong we  know it's wrong  [Music]  you  [Music]